你干的事是没有记得的事
你每天干的事
第二天就清零了
你唯一价心的方法
就是在考个正书
熬子里
当时的价心
能加碼的不算
你那个价碼都是
价小数点啊
但是如果你做的是自己的事
你今天记得一点
明天记得一点
后天记得一点
那是你自己的事
这个事是
是OK的
我们把话说过来
其实我以前是赚钱的
好几个有点用的
看探决策知系统
还是我写的
我后来不做了为什么
因为做完一个
才在做一个
然后下一个想不到
没有记得你们注意的吗
我以前做资讯
包括演讲演一样
你会发现也不行
为什么
因为你会发现
做资讯成了
其实没有第二个资讯的
没成更没有资讯的
所以你会发现
看了客战产党
它是没有资讯的
它是没有的
但是你有没有发现
现在我做的这个事
我现在做了三件事
全都是有复理的
比如说头积
头积
我哪怕
六十个
七十个
我仍然可以做头积
为什么
它需要提低吗
需要熬夜加班吗
不需要
它只需要判断你
一旦掌握了以后
你会发现
越往后女月说
你的经验就越丰富
然后还有一个东西
什么的
还有一个东西
其实就是
就是支持一个东西
支持这个东西特别好
你会发现
你拿我来说
我的用过量会越来来的大
别翻车
别不要隔久才
隔久才能够出闻
它不是说
它看着好像很聪明的
出闻
它没有更长的演光
记住
如果你总是能给别人
就你别老想的自己成功
你只要能帮更多的人成功
给更多的人带来加势
你就成功了
就这么简单
如果很多人不理解这个概念
如果你
如果你明白这个国际
然后你就会发现
你的用过量会越来越大
你的富购会越来越多
你的客单价会越来越高
我们我们再说一个小伙企
我们很多老伙企
是在社区里的
他就老伙也知道我的社区
大概是什么费用
我们的费用是什么事
我们的社区里
和别人社区不一样
你看回家
就有了一个什么叫什么叫故意的
我的社区随时和推沸
老伙都知道吧
我的社区随时和推沸的
不是说你进来以后
给你的三天
是用七天是用不是的
随时和推沸
对吧
老伙就没有都知道
对不对
你真的有人
三百六十四天的时候推沸的
人家的社区
你整人的钱吗
不是这样的
这什么是你要帮他承长
你就帮他承长了
你才能更好的承长